oh hello I didn't see you there he
didn't happen to see my boy toy did you
he went off to the powder room it hasn't
yet come back oh well let's just pass
the time with a spine chilling tale
after all nothing gets me more in the
mood for round two then attract into the
darkest parts the human mind oh here's a
goodie have you heard the one about the
surgeon in the elevator I should have
warned him about going down can you let
dr. Nichols know that I'm on my way down
to or one late night dr. Klein very
thanks hold the elevator sorry little
puzzles bad day actually a pretty bad
tell me about it uh let's see woke up
and had a two hour surgery that went for
out wait you're actually gonna tell me
about it I thought that's what you meant
no
you you work here hi no
ok I do is the thing
going tom we're going up we're going up
that's cool we're clearly going down
that was a patient of mine how was a
patient that I operated on he died on
the operating table maybe you're
mistaken no his wristband was rented
that's a morgue tag light for one you
have
going down you'd think a doctor would
know that you could add years to your
life simply by taking the stairs really
gets the blood pumping isn't that right
honey bun oh I love you too I knew I
returned by the way that would be just
her well I have a few more stories of
scary with so be sure to LIKE and
subscribe speaking of scars
how about a kiss they made a mistake
maybe I should just go back to the door
vamps are real they own Morganville but
you're safe with us